- Do I look masculine?
Okay, cool.
(instrumental music)
- Today we are dressing up as men.
- I've never heard of drag kings before.
- I'm just really excited about stuffing
and having just like a huge (bleep)
- I don't know why I'm so uncomfortable
to dress as a guy and act as a guy.
- What if I'm hotter as a dude?
- I really want to know
how they're going to contour my face.
- My biggest issue is I'm
wondering where my boobs
are going to go.
- Why do you think no one
knows what drag king is?
- So drag is already a
subculture of the traditional
gay/lesbian and trans community.
Drag queens are the more
flamboyant, over the top,
they stand out in crowds more.
- There has been drag kings,
it's just not seen as a spotlight.
It's still a man's world in a way, it is,
even though they're dressed as women.
- What inspired you to start doing drag?
- I've been dancing since I was three.
They always made me do the girl side
and I was looking at the guys
and what they were doing.
- How did you learn
all the make up skills?
- The university of U2. A lot of homework.
- I was born as a woman
biologically, so I still do
what I have to do to be a drag king.
- It's just this alter ego,
like amplified persona of yourself.
- [Havok] It's whatever
you're feeling that day.
- When I was watching you, I was like,
I'm so turned on right
now, this is insane.
- [Landon] You're welcome.
- With the boobs, where do they go?
- Under your armpit.
- They don't go there.
- There's a technique, they'll get there.
- This is my goal: my boyfriend
is going to be in the crowd.
I want to get him so sexually confused.
It's going to be great.
I think I can do it.
- I'm in, I'm in.
- All right, we're doing it.
(electronic music)
- Two hours until we slay these bitches.
- Do you fix my, make my
eyebrows more like manly?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Men have more top brow than women,
so yours goes a little bit higher.
- I feel like I'm really
out of my own right now.
- This is what my mustache
is going to be made out of.
- This is so awesome.
- [Candage] How does it
feel to have chest hair?
- You're looking pretty
manly right now, for sure.
- Such attention to detail, I love it.
- I feel like I just have a
bunch of pubes glued to my face.
- You look like a new human.
You look really cool, though.
- My biggest fear is that I'm gonna turn
into a 1970s porn star.
- Luckily I'm not too boobaged.
- These are going to be gone.
- Wait, what do you do again?
- I get preferably duct tape
and I take strips of it
and I cover my nipples
with like bandaids or
something and I just go back,
back and up, back and up, back and up.
- My penis!
I have my penis.
- Landon gave me an awesome dick.
It feels really cool.
It's like kind of sexually excited me.
- These...
I love being a guy.
- I have to figure out what my name is.
- [Phantom] You have to choose a name
that fits you, not just the
one character you're doing.
- Okay, Just In.
- Ponds up her skirt so I
thought you should know that.
- I really want to see myself.
When is this happening?
- It's weird because I
have cramps right now
but I also can feel my dick.
- Me too!
- So are you ready for this?
- Yes.
I'm scared.
- Three, two, one.
- Oh my God!
- Oh my God.
Wait, it looks like you gave
me a different bone structure.
- Holy (bleep).
- Woah.
- I look like Ron Jeremy.
- Would I date myself?
Probably.
- What did you do?
- I didn't have many expectations
so this is really crazy.
- I look like an Abe Lincoln
you'd want to (bleep).
- Oh my God, I really look like a dude.
(electronic music)
- Thank you, thank you.
- I'm so ready.
- Let's (bleep) do this.
(electronic music)
- Hello, everyone, welcome to BuzzFeed's
first Drag King Show.
(applause)
Please give it up for our first performer,
Phillip N. Cider.
- I have an entirely different face.
I didn't want Landon messing with my eyes,
and I didn't want to take off nail polish
and I'm still just 100% a dude.
- Interacting with the girls
and like grinding on them
and putting my hat on
them, that was so much fun.
- Once you get your sock in your pants,
you walk a different way.
It was really cool, I loved it.
- I was really, really nervous.
What I realize is it's
just about elevating
parts of yourself that you
really don't get to express
in everyday life.
- I could see the terrified
look on my boyfriend's face
but it was awesome to
watch it go from terror
to slightly impressed to
like, totally impressed,
to actually having a lot of fun.
So much of it is just the way you look
and your body language
and your eye contact.
Everyone acted like they've
never seen glitter before.
I feel like I invented
glitter when I did that.
- I thought it would be pretty
easy but it's really hard
and it's really an art to act like this.
I think that Freddie Mercury
is looking down on me
being like, "Okay, she has my blessing,
"she did a good job."
- I talked to the game about
being a good-looking guy.
I can confidently say like yeah,
I would be a good-looking guy.
- I had so many girls come up to me
that they were so confused,
like they didn't want to think
I was sexy.
I achieved my goal: I wanted
to turn girls on and I did.
- This is by far, hands
down, without a doubt
the most eye-opening
adventurous thing I've done
in my entire life, not
even like one of the.
No, it like is the.
- Mad love to all the drag kings.
You guys work your asses off
and you made us look amazing.
You made us perform well.
We all felt like (bleep) hot-ass dudes.